left-hander tarek school tonight making
his 13th start of the season
it's his fourth inner league start
amongst all american league rookies he
leads
in strikeouts with 81 and in major
league baseball he's got the highest
whiff rate second highest lift rate
of anybody on his change up at 45.1
percent
now he's facing paul goldschmidt here's
the 2-2
a drive to deep left center field on the
run goes badou and he's got it
akil badu covered a little bit of ground
there i initially thought that ball was
gonna carry there's no wind tonight
flags are blowing straight down
so he must have got in a little bit more
in the kitchen than i thought
but dude you can see it very good route
to the baseball
and he has plenty of time catches it
just shy of the warning track
so again being aggressive derek skubal
makes goldschmidt
swing the bat here's nolan aronado the
one-two
right at jamer candelaria good start for
derek school
17 pitches to get through the first the
cardinals leave a man stranded here
comes detroit johann oviedo is on the
mound for the cardinals still looking
for that first major league victory
and it's a hyundai pitch arsenal for the
cardinal right-hander good fastball
change up not much slider fastball
slider guy
can get up to 98 good stuff
grossman is hitless in his last 16.
trying to change that here into right
now oh for his last 17 nice play
tommy edmond in right field tonight owen
two on scope
grounded over the mound fielded behind
second sosa
throws out his counterpart edmundo
throws out jonathan scope
two up two down the runners lead at
first and third
off of oviedo the young force play at
second
and out at second good go one
six four on this play and hopefully
oviedo is okay
20 pitches in each of the last couple of
innings for tarik school 20 or more he
needed
20 to get through the third 28 through
the second where he had the two
strikeouts now he faces nolan aronado
aaron otto pops it up foul territory
rogers and cabrera
converge and it's cabrera who makes the
grab on two fronts good job by mickey
getting over there and staying with that
pitch
or with that foul wall talk about scuba
and a quick pitch at bat well he gets an
hour right at the railing by the
photographer as well at the end of the
visiting dugout
boy good to get rid of that that hitter
that's big time
here's tyler o'neil another one too
got him swinging third strikeout for
tarik skubal
maybe one of the best sliders we've seen
him throw molina
to right field long run for mazzara he's
been in good condition so he catches up
to it
that's a second straight one two three
frame for derek skubal and now you got a
chance
for a run here in the fourth nomar
mazzara singled his last time up
2-0 broken bat right back to the pitcher
[Applause]
maybe the third he will dig for third
the throw is off
line and he's in there with a head first
slide oviedo had the right
idea the ball sharply hit to him and he
knows that he has
badou trapped at third base but he
rushes his throw
you see arnotto was moving towards third
base and he just airmailed it
not even closer and i don't even make
attempt because he knew
the deuce scores easily and then mazara
looking as he's rounding second
yeah i got a chance for three here and
he makes it
bases are drunk with tigers
for jake rogers you only have one out
drives one down the left field line
that's gonna find a corner missouri
trots home
here comes willy castro harold castro
stops at third
jake rogers has himself a two-run double
good for jake a little bit of redemption
there he had two pitches that he could
handle
and then he gets another one he doesn't
miss it pulls it right down the left
field line
it's a little slider that basically
doesn't break at all
just spins jake hits it hard into the
corner
azara scores easily really castro comes
around he scores
harold didn't get that good a turn
around second so it was up to chip hale
to put the brakes on and he did
now here's jonathan scope no major
leaguer has more hits
since may 22nd than jonathan scope
that one is hammered deep left center
field
good oh man little question about that
one chef
that ball was pulverized number 14 is a
three-run shot in a six-nothing lead for
the tigers well you're talking about a
quadruple a buggy whip there it was
right there a hanging slider and he has
been so hot
when he gets his pitch he does not miss
it that was a hanger and boy did it go
out of here in a hurry
that's a big time home run right there
baby big time
boy was that a beauty or what paul just
jumps off his back man
that is a blast it sure was nothing to
the count he grounded to second base
first time up
nupar hits it out to left catch is made
sosa tagging up and lars newbar as his
first rbi in the major leagues a line
out to left to bring in
sosa and gets the cardinals on the board
two really good at bats so far
by new bar and it's a little reward for
that staying in there and getting his
first rbi love it
goldschmidt has sent one to the track
deep left center
also popped out to second and goldie
pulls it fair
inside the third base line off the
sidewall
de young will score on a rocket off the
bat of paul goldsmith to make it
six to two the cardinals are down by a
grand slam now
it's a six to two game as goldsmith
drives in
run number 39 in 2021 that puts runners
at the corners
but he is trying to bunt and he bumps it
to the right side really good play right
there
they get him at first but he gets the
run
home and the tigers now lead at 7-2
so a really nice job by harold castro to
get another run home
and here's jake rogers the 1-2 to center
field
carlson will watch it drop and he'll
have to chase it down
all the way to the wall another run is
home
rogers has found the fountain of youth
and speed
and it who says catchers can't run
all you have to do is hit it and make
that center fielder chase the ball
he goes right up the middle you can see
the swing was different see how he kept
his front side in
ball gets by carlson he has to chase him
down and then it's just a race look at
the man go
and he will tell all his friends who
needs to slide how many catchers do you
see hit
triples three balls two strikes
cardinals down to their last strike
this crowd would love to see daniel
norris finish this off right here
the payoff from norris on the ground to
third
scooped up by jammer candelario crossed
the diamond to scope and the tigers take
game one against the cardinals
beautiful a convincing 8-2 knockout led
by jonathan scope offensively
tigers beat the cardinals